ça lui a fait manquer tout alors tu veux
qu'on chante quoi ce soir j'ai pris ça
au cas où on vous a pas invités pour
chanter on vous invitait pour nous
garder aka s'cusez moi je pensais que
vous étiez surbooké entre vos super
boulot et vauvy de rêve
ouais c'est mon cas on est tous sur elle
en met plein dessus terre l'apc genre à
avoir été nourris au sein je trouve est
prête à tout pour échanger avec vous
tous les ans un concert est organisé
pour soutenir les troupes en europe
un dernier spectacle tout ensemble alors
qu'ils me sui wa grave
bienvenue en espagne bella donc là c'est
la face des approches mais après c'est
avec vous qu'on passe à la soupe négatif
pour moi sur cette tournée on a trois
ponts vous chantez exclusivement les
chansons des autres genres groupe de
reprises elle joue l'intimidation
on a qu'a fait avec truc à nous une
battle
non
nous on fait tout avec la bougie
c'est bizarre que tout le monde soit
meilleur sur notre propre terrain qu que
nous les filles 11 12 le boul
allo leur prouver qu'on a sur mon label
veut signal ces groupes mais on veut pas
lé bella on te veux toi
pardon je n'ai rien une famille on se
souvient les unes les autres
on est comme des soeurs ouvrait ses
aubret je crois je peux pas je fais
partie d'un groupe vicat c'est une
chance a pas laissé passer
m
dans tes rêves
clap de fin des pelles harry john ça
sent vraiment les adieux
mes gars qu'est ce que tu veux non si tu
perds je vais pleurer
peut-être
[Musique]